[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers
guten abend in allen an diesem dienstag
geben sie uns 20 minuten für den
nachrichtenüberblick katja hat nachher
den sport es ist schön genannt und
natürlich steht dieser tag ganz im
zeichen der politik
machtpoker bei der union es geht um die
zukunft von armin laschet und dessen
wunsch vielleicht doch noch kanzler zu
werden
herantasten an die ampel spd grüne und
fdp wollen die gemeinsamkeiten für eine
mögliche koalition ausloten
hilfe im tankstellen- chaos in
großbritannien soll jetzt die armee
eingreifen weil immer mehr zapfsäulen
keinen sprit mehr haben
wir beginnen heute abend in berlin wo
vor und hinter den kulissen gerungen und
gefeilscht wird um personal und um
allianzen bei der cdu csu steht im
mittelpunkt die frage nach der
politischen zukunft des wahlverlierers
wie lange kann sich armin laschet halten
denn nicht nur in den unionsparteien
rumort es auch bei deren
bundestagsabgeordneten durch das
schlechte wahlergebnis ist die neue cdu
csu fraktion im bundestag ziemlich
geschrumpft von 246 abgeordnete auf
196 das sind 50 weniger um die frage wie
wen und wann diese fraktion ihren neuen
vorsitzenden welt gibt es heftige
diskussionen
denn das ist einer der wichtigsten jobs
in der cdu überhaupt und das ist auch
eine entscheidung an der sich die
zukunft für armin laschet ausrichten
könnte zumal der druck durch den
csu-chef steigt in ist ramms berichtet
eine machtprobe für armin laschet in der
fraktionssitzung wollte er doch den
amtierenden vorsitzenden ralph brinkhaus
nur kommissarisch nochmals antreten
lassen um vielleicht selber nachzurücken
nun der kompromiss brinkhaus weitere
amtszeit soll auf sechs monate begrenzt
sein das zeigt auch dass wir
handlungsfähig sind das obwohl es da er
augenscheinlich unterschiedliche
meinungen gab also wir in der lage waren
lagen kompromisse herzustellen und das
zeigt auch das cdu aber auch csu sehr
daran interessiert sind jetzt ruhe
reinzukriegen die fraktion muss
handlungsfähig seien sie braucht einen
klaren auftrag an einen vorsitzenden wir
wollen ordnung und dazu gehört dass wir
heute auch entsprechend wahlen
durchführen laschet kämpft zur stunde in
der fraktionssitzung um sein politisches
überleben er verteidigt seine
resthoffnung auf jamaika doch er bekommt
gegenwind für seinen plan auch als
zweitplatzierter eine koalition zu
versuchen sagte aber auch ausdrücklich
dazu dass erstens aus diesem
wahlergebnis kein automatischer
regierungsauftrag abzuleiten ist
zweitens wir uns verantwortung nicht
entziehen am mittag war csu-chef söder
in der bayerischen landesvertretung
deutlich auf konfrontationskurs zu
laschet gegangen er erkannte die
niederlage der union an und verneinte
einen klaren regierungsauftrag den sieg
der spd müsste man innerlich annehmen
sie ist es auch wichtig dass man ein
wahlergebnis respektiert dazu gehört für
mich auch vom stil was ich an der stelle
noch einmal weil es bislang kaum erfolgt
ist wohlauf scholz gratuliere die besten
chancen kanzler zu werden hat derzeit
olaf scholz eindeutig die
fraktionssitzung dauert an der showdown
um den vorsitz ist erstmal verschoben
armin laschet hat ein bisschen zeit
gewonnen mehr nicht
und theo koll ist live für uns vor der
unionsfraktion im deutschen bundestag
und theo tja was ist zu hören was sagt
dieser tag über die politische zukunft
von armin laschet
nun dieser tag sendet sehr gemischte
signale eben hat offensichtlich eine der
fraktions vize vorsitzenden gitta
connemann ziemlich entnervt gefragt wer
denn eigentlich verantwortung für dieses
schlechte wahlergebnis übernimmt auf der
anderen seite hat armin laschet es
offensichtlich geschafft ein kompromiss
zu zimmern also der eben beschriebene
kompromiss dass ralph brinkhaus der
fraktionsvorsitzende für sechs monate
gewählt wird das ist sehr viel länger
als armin laschet eigentlich wollte er
wollte die position offen halten und
ralph brinkhaus wollte für ein jahr
gewählt werden der hintergrund ist es
wenn die union nicht im kanzleramt endet
sondern als größte oppositionspartei
dann ist der fraktionsvorsitz die
wichtigste die machtvollste position in
der union und die wollte armin laschet
noch offen halten sein schutzpanzer
seien größer ist immer noch die aussicht
nach einer gescheiterten hampel
verhandlung auf eine jamaika position so
lange es diese option gibt wird
wahrscheinlich keiner liegen so stark
kritisieren oder vielleicht aus der
partei spitze vertreiben dass man damit
die jamaika position verliert aber in
dieser schutzpanzer wird dünner t und
dann müssen noch über den csu chef reden
welche rolle spielt markus söder dessen
äußerungen wir haben sie gerade gesehen
und gehört heute für laschet ja nur als
heftige seitenhiebe zu verstehen sein
konnten
absolut also er spielt hier eine
doppelrolle muss man sagen auf der einen
seite hat er ja diesen kompromiss die
man offensichtlich gefunden hat rund um
den fraktionsvorsitz mitgetragen und
vielleicht auch mitgeholfen ihn zu
finden auf der anderen seite hat der
armee laschet mit mehreren äußerungen ja
heute heftig auf die füße getreten also
er hat ja sogar von einer stilfrage
gesprochen dass man olaf scholz
gratulieren müsse das hat armin laschet
ja vermieden armin laschet hat dann im
grunde zurückgeschlagen und hat gesagt
also eben in der fraktion so wird es
jedenfalls berichtet es gebe kein haupt
wahlgewinner also insofern stellt er
diese position infrage unterm strich
bleibt diese politische freundschaft
zwischen armin laschet und markus söder
eine sehr spezielle so kann man sagen je
hässlicher dank
die besten chancen kanzler zu werden hat
derzeit olaf scholz das sagte wir haben
es gerade gehört csu chef markus söder
die spd müsste dazu grüne und fdp mit an
bord holen zwei politische lager die
eher auseinander liegen sondierungen für
ein sogenanntes ampelbündnis stehen
jetzt am zunächst wohl zwischen den
beiden kleineren parteien die spd drückt
aber auch aus tempo wie patricia
wiedemeier berichtet es gibt viele neue
viele junge viele unbekannte gesichter
seit heute im bundestag nicht nur bei
den grünen auch bei der spd die fraktion
deutlich größer als zuvor 206
abgeordnete mehr als die hälfte von
ihnen neulinge nur der
fraktionsvorsitzende ist der alte und
rolf mützenich machte gleich klare
ansagen man habe grüne und fdp für diese
woche eingeladen zu sondierungen aber
ich glaube beide kleinen parteien müssen
sich klar darüber werden dass das
schauspiel was sie vor vier jahren hier
manchmal auf balkonen
absolviert haben nicht den aufgaben
gerecht wird umso mehr hoffe ich dass
wir dann auch schnell zueinander finden
zueinander finden in einer
ampelkoalition das scheint auch die
präferenz der grünen zu sein die spd hat
stark zur gewonnen die union hat stark
verloren wir werden selbstverständlich
mit allen demokratischen parteien reden
aber
ist es auch wahrscheinlicher dass es am
ende zu einer ampel kommt erste
sondierungsgespräche führen die grünen
parteivorsitzenden zusammen
vorabsprachen der beiden wie gestern die
runde machten dass harbeck vizekanzler
werden solle sorgten für heftige
proteste in der partei zwangen ihn heute
dazu klarzustellen dass es sich geradezu
nicht geziemt ins personalspekulationen
einzusteigen bevor wir überhaupt
sondierungsgespräche aufgenommen haben
oder eine regierung haben die frage bei
vizekanzler wird ist völlig irrelevant
wäre mir nicht meinen kanzler jetzt gehe
es erst einmal darum vertrauen zu
schaffen meinen grüne und auch die fdp
ein wesentliches element dieser vor
sondierung ist ja dass man vertrauen
zueinander aufbaut dass man in ruhe
sprechen kann dass man vertraulich
sprechen kann und deshalb bestimmen
diejenigen die an diesem gespräch
teilnehmen und das sind für uns
christian lindner volker wissing davor
sitzen der generalsekretär wie sie sich
mit ihrem bundestreffen noch ist offen
ob olaf scholz es schafft grüne und fdp
für eine ampel zu gewinnen ist bleibt
spannend
so ist es jetzt unsere nächstes thema
dann gehe ich bis nach karlsruhe
das ist in den vergangenen jahrzehnten
zu einem geflügelten wort geworden
gemeint ist das bundesverfassungsgericht
das heute vor 70 jahren seine arbeit
aufnahm
feierliche eröffnung damals unter
anderem mit bundespräsident und
bundeskanzler seitdem haben die
richterinnen und richter am obersten
deutschen gericht viele politisch und
gesellschaftlich brisante themen
verhandelt es ging um
schwangerschaftsabbruch um hartz 4 und
zuletzt um den klimaschutz christoph
schneider berichtet es war die
bahnbrechende zukunftsentscheidungen die
das bundesverfassungsgericht zum
klimaschutz ende april bekannt gab
wieder einmal muss die politik
nachbessern künftige rechte junger
menschen müssen heute schon geschützt
werden
letztendlich gibt eben moment alles wird
und so alle auch noch viel mehr
betreffen vor allem eben wenn wir jetzt
nicht ausreichend handeln seit nunmehr
70 jahren handelt das
bundesverfassungsgericht unermüdlich
wenn es angerufen wird angefangen hat es
in einem kleinen gebäude in karlsruhe
dann zog man in den bekannten komplex
mit viel glas um die transparenz war
nötig nach der furchtbaren ns-herrschaft
das grundgesetz trägt die handschrift
des nie wieder nie wieder sollten
menschen so entrechtet so erniedrigt
werden können wie es im dritten reich
der fall war und deshalb wurde auch eine
instanz geschaffen das
bundesverfassungsgericht die unabhängig
in letzter instanz sicherstellen soll
dass staatliche gewalt grundrechte der
menschen nicht verletzen kann in seinen
grundrechten verletzt sah sich helmut
feldmann mit dem umstrittenen gesetz zur
sterbehilfe er klagte und bekam recht
zur menschenwürde gehöre auch ein recht
auf selbstbestimmtes sterben sagte das
verfassungsgericht im februar vergangen
jahres wenn menschen schwer krank sind
leiden und eine heilung nicht mehr
möglich ist und die möchten sterben dass
das auch menschenwürde ist auch eine
frage der menschenwürde die
einschränkung von grundrechten während
der korona pandemie im spätherbst will
das verfassungsgericht zur sogenannten
bundes notbremse entscheiden auch nach
70 jahren bleibt das
bundesverfassungsgericht gefragt wie nie
auftrag gerechtigkeit wie viel macht hat
das bundesverfassungsgericht um die
frage geht es in einer zdf-dokumentation
nach dem heute-journal update um 0.15
und jetzt schon in unserer zdf mediathek
in hamburg haben ermittler privaträume
und büros der hamburger finanzbehörden
im zusammenhang mit strafbaren comex
aktiengeschäften durchsucht wegen des
anfangsverdachts auf begünstigung wird
gegen zwei männer und eine frau
ermittelt unter ihnen ist auch der
ehemalige spd-bundestagsabgeordnete
johannes kahrs
federführend bei der aktion war die
staatsanwaltschaft in köln sie ist
zuständig für die inzwischen als
straftat gewerteten comex steuer deals
bei denen sich beschuldigte vom staat
mehrfach steuern erstatten ließen
leere regale im supermarkt möbelstücke
nicht lieferbar überall fehlendes
personal
daran hatten sich die briten schon seit
monaten gewöhnen müssen was aber jetzt
an britischen tankstellen los ist hat es
so im praxisalltag noch nicht gegeben
gesperrte zapfsäulen fast überall kein
sprit verfügbar es fehlt an personal für
die tanklaster jetzt hält sich die armee
bereit denn die lage ist prekär andreas
stamm
ein land fährt dem sprit hinterher und
die reise endet seit fünf tagen oft in
einer langen schlange vereinzelt rasten
verzweifelte sprit suche aus in london
droht dieser fahrer mit einem messer
lässt nicht locker zurück bleiben wollen
und wohl eine prellung mehr als die
hälfte der tankstellen in england
ballungsräumen sitzt komplett auf dem
trockenen
seit drei tagen suche ich benzin ich
habe vier kleine kinder die ich überall
hinfahren muss
fahrermangel verstärkt durch den braig
sieg wären wir noch in der eu hätten wir
dieses problem nicht
es mangelt an lkw fahrern die treibstoff
aus raffinerien liefern können
panikkäufe haben nun die versorgung
vielerorts zusammenbrechen lassen
insgesamt fehlen auf der insel 100.000
fahrer zehntausende prüfungen fielen
wegen corona aus bis zu 30.000 aus der
eu hat der bhc rexit vertrieben in der
tank krise werden nun forderungen laut
systemrelevante berufsgruppen die ärzte
oder polizisten sollten zuerst an die
zapfsäule damit sie zur arbeit können
nicht nötig auf die regierung die
meisten hätten vollgetankt die schlangen
werden sich auflösen
aus der industrie heißt es dass die
versorgung der tankstellen sich wieder
richtung normal bewegt dazu möchte ich
wirklich alle betten wieder normales
tank verhalten an den tag zu legen
sollte sich die situation nicht
entspannen könnten bis zu 150 armee
fahrer aushelfen es soll 5000 dreimonats
visa für eu trucker geben wenig
verlockend zur wirtschaftsvertreter
fahrer aus europa werden kaum schlange
stehen der mangel an trackern bleibt und
der nächste versorgungsengpass kommt
bestimmt
und jetzt zu einer katastrophe in
brasilien die ein gerichtliches
nachspiel in deutschland hat verklagt
wurde der tüv süd und darum geht es 2009
10 in der brasilianischen gemeinde bruma
den jo bricht der damm einer
eisenerzmine eine schlammlawine giftig
und tödlich ergießt sich ins tal
mindestens 270 menschen sterben tüv süd
prüfer in brasilien hatten nur wenige
monate zuvor den damals sicher erklärt
angehörige und die gemeinde verlangen
jetzt vor dem landgericht münchen
schadensersatz simon pfanzelt als wie
gustavo barroso und seine familie
vergangene woche in brasilien besuchen
ist die trauer mit händen zu greifen von
seiner schwester isabella sind ihnen nur
bilder geblieben erinnerungen ich
überlegen es ist schwer denn jedes mal
wenn wir fotos sehen und unseren sie
erinnern kommt alles zurück die ganze
geschichte droht ist oder
romazzino im januar 2009 10 das
rückhaltebecken der eisenerzmine bricht
die schlammlawine tötet isabella
insgesamt sterben mindestens 270
menschen trägt der tüv süd dafür die
verantwortung
darum geht es heute prozess der in eine
tochtergesellschaft des deutschen prüf
unternehmens hatte den damm für stabil
erklärt wenige monate vor der
katastrophe die zertifizierung hat dazu
geführt dass keine
stützungsmaßnahmen eingeleitet wurden
das nicht evakuiert wurde und dass es so
zu so vielen todesopfern kommen konnte
die kläger werfen dem tüv süd vor zu
niedrige sicherheitsstandards angelegt
zu haben mutmaßlich um lukrative folge
verträge mit dem brasilianischen
bergbaukonzern vale abschließen zu
können der tüv bestreitet das der damm
war im zeitpunkt der stabilitäts-
erklärungen stabil wir haben auch sehr
klar unsere überzeugung zum ausdruck
gebracht dass die stabilitäts
erklärungen rechtmäßig im einklang mit
den anwendbaren brasilianischen gesetzen
und dem stand der technik abgegeben
wurden die ursache des dammbruchs sei
ungeklärt so der tüv fuß da wo barroso
sieht das anders er ist für den prozess
extra nach münchen gereist von der
deutschen justiz verspricht er sich
gerechtigkeit
und jetzt in der sendung der sport &
tears katja am abend in der fußball
champions league dürfte vor allem die
brust von leipzigs christoph in den
kokon etwas breiter sein als sonst nach
seinem herausragenden auftritt beim 6 0
am samstag gegen die hertha rb coach des
teams sagte der junge hat keine
schwächen das kann er heute abend wieder
beweisen leipzig empfängt den fc brügge
christopher nun kongo ist der mann der
stunde in leipzig europas topklubs haben
ihn längst im visier gegen hertha hat er
zweimal getroffen gleich dreimal gegen
manchester city im auftaktspiel das für
rb 13 6 verloren ging leipzig in der
champions league unter zugzwang auch
wenn es der trainer abschwächt beim
ersten heimspiel sollen drei punkte her
unserer mannschaft jetzt hat keinen job
ja das für spieler mit freude jetzt dass
wir verstehen mehr
das spiel stehen cd von von ein spiel
ist oder wie unser fußball ist brücke
der vermeintlich leichtesten
gruppengegner dem starensemble von
paris-longchamp aber trotzdem der
belgische meister ein unentschieden ab
heute spielt auch noch der bvb zu hause
gegen sporting lissabon und morgen sind
in der königsklasse dann der vfl
wolfsburg und die bayern gefragt bayern
schöpft gegen dynamo kiew beinahe aus
dem vollen nur toni so und como werben
vielen como kann immerhin wieder
mittrainieren coach nagelsmann wir nach
dem 3 zu 0 gegen barcelona in der gruppe
klare verhältnisse schaffen am ende geht
es um das zu bestätigen dass wir
vielleicht einer der favoriten sein
können und wäre ja das ding gewinnen
will muss am ende die meisten spiele
gewonnen haben und das versuchen wir
nach dem 0 0 gegen will und der 1 3
niederlage gegen hoffenheim in der
bundesliga in wolfsburg gegen sevilla
wieder in die erfolgsspur die
möglichkeit und muscheln chancen werden
und wenn man da auch noch rücksichtlose
wird im verteidigen
dann da machen wir große schritte 13.000
fans wollen dass vfl heimspiel und den
nächsten schritt sehen
alle highlights der champions league
dann morgen abend live im zdf von 23 uhr
an danke katja so jetzt ein roter
teppich mit fast anderthalb jahren
verspätung der neue bond feiert
weltpremiere natürlich nicht irgendwo
sondern in london
die ersten gäste sind schon da von der
königlichen familie kommen auch einige
und in gut einer halben stunde gehts los
keine zeit zu sterben ist der letzte
band mit daniel craig über zweieinhalb
stunden lang die fans atmen auf fast
wäre der film wegen co oder gar nicht
mehr in die kinos gekommen
sturm und regen sind für morgen angesagt
mehr dazu gleich von ist anthony so viel
von uns hier für heute ich empfehle das
heute-journal natürlich mit der kollegin
marietta slomka um 21.45 und morgen sind
wir wieder für sie da punkt 7 bis dann
in allen einen angenehmen abend tschüss
[Musik]
ein schokolade und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter wir erwarten morgen ein
sturmtief und das erreicht vor allem die
nordsee aber im vorfeld bereits in der
nacht zieht von süden her schauer und
gewitter weiter richtung norden aber
auch im tagesverlauf gibt es schauer vor
allem dann am nachmittag kräftiger regen
an der nordsee teils mit viel wind also
sturm und schwere sturmböen sind hier
dabei in der nacht also im süden schauer
und gewitter die auch ziehen und sich
allmählich nach norden verlagern nach
westen hin ist es eher trocken aber
recht kühl weil sieben bis acht grad vor
allem in den westlichen mittelgebirgen
sonst zum beispiel im südosten bei 12
grad morgen dann am vormittag schauer
und gewitter die weiter nach norden
ziehen im südwesten ist es aufgelockert
und am nachmittag liegt dann der wind
vor allem an der nordsee zu schauer und
gewitter sind dabei und eben auch
sturmböen sowie schwere sturmböen und
gewitter auch nach osten hinter bei
temperatur und maximal 20 grad im
südosten zum beispiel sonst im westen
bei 13 bis 14 grad die nächsten tage
werden dann etwas ruhiger einzig im
norden ist es windig mit schauern
donnerstag 12 bis 17 grad ja und zur ab
freitag etwas wärmer ein schöner abend